infatigable il enchaîne vélo course avec
une facilité déconcertante à carreaux à
un an de guerriers une mentalité de
faire son tour de france et son combat
une bataille contre les préjugés sur les
diabétiques
il ya les écoles comme saint cyr l'école
des mines des écoles d'ingénieurs de
magistrature qui sont interdites
moi je sais pas encore ce que je vais
faire buteur mais ce que je sais c'est
que j'ai j'ai pas envie qu'on maternisé
métier ak roi est équipé d'une pompe à
insuline grâce à un badge il peut
contrôler son taux de glycémie un allié
indispensable par son besoin sucre
diagnostiqué diabétique type 1 1 il y a
deux ans après un coma qui lui fait
frôler la mort il décide de repousser
les limites de son corps et se lancent
des défis celui ci le mènera de la
frontière belge au pied des pyrénées
catalanes plus de 2000 kilomètres aux
côtés de son père et sa famille il peut
on en même pas trois minutes retrouvé
son cours normal
- il faut dix minutes facile un moment
de réconfort en famille avant de rallier
la ville étape de shark
il est très tenace très courageux et de
volonté qui n'est pas ça normal je pense
que beaucoup de diabétiques
insulinodépendants ont cette
caractéristique comme chaque matin ils
doivent calculer leur bien-être
c'est un calcul qui coûtent très
compliqué parce qu'ils changent tous les
jours si jamais les mêmes valeurs
ça donne un caractère une vente et de la
normale et puis voilà je crois que ce
qui fait c'est même pas imaginable
même en tant que papa quoi c'est juste
incroyable pour financer sa cause ils
ont créé l'association just dite est
lancée une cagnotte en ligne mais
attention ne lui parlez pas de super
héros akaroa veut prouver que l'exploit
est à la portée de tous après le sacre
des bleus champions du monde
il espère lui aussi décroché les étoiles